ce que l'émission n'est pas trop
dangereux parce que là c'est vrai enfin
valérie oui alors moi effectivement moi
je suis je fais partie de celles qui
apprécient cette émission effectivement
hier moi je me suis inquiété pour eux je
me suis dit effectivement dans cette
émission là il n'y a pas de caméraman
oui et de prix de production réellement
puisque ce sont les cameramans qui sont
embarqués dans l'aventuré
c'est eux mêmes qui se filment et donc
je m'interrogeais et notamment pourquoi
on a exfiltré l'âme parce qu'on s'est
dit s'il lui arrive quelque chose de la
nuit personne ne pourra venir la
chercher
là maintenant ils sont obligés d'être
surveillés moi je dirige et l'obligé
c'est à dire si tu aimes pas en montrer
la difficulté c'est pas comparable
moundir les apprentis ou contrats mais
quand même j'ai connu de la justice a
perdu 6 kilos s'est jeté une crevette
ouais bah serait que tu as bien repris
oui ça va tu pèses 63 mais ça va ça va
face aux young c'est extrêmement
sécurisé zoom balise de détresse en
avion sera belle et sacré en sept
minutes d'hélicoptère peut arriver et dé
d'arqués et en plaisant l'équipe temps
réalisés en détresse c'est un peu dur en
7 minutes et un hélico karim l'examen
sur une autre émission ne peut pas les
armes possibles il ya un médecin cubain
de l'équipe parmi les cameramans correct
donc si il faut pas dire c'est trop
dangereux c'est des piqûres mundo
moustiquaires et annonce pourrait faire
état grave était sinon aulas est dans le
vrai problème c'est je trouve ça fou un
petit peu loquace quand même à koh lanta
par exemple c'est plus un jeu de survie
ma pensée a pas de l'attraction phare il
aimerait vivre et souscrivez là là là
c'est trop là parce que là bas mais non
c'est pas trop en fait y'a que ça dans
l'émission quelques moustiques qui
piquent l'âme donc du coup il insisté
dessus ils allaient plusieurs jours mais
ça n'a aucun intérêt ou s'ennuie
profondément pendant quelques heures il
ne se passe rien isabelle je vais vous
dire le problème dans ce genre moi je
moi j'aime beaucoup l'émission de m6 la
ccq l'étain c'est fait oui donc les le
problème de ce genre de mission c'est
que quand on a un organisme habitués à
une nourriture européenne et qu'on se
met à manger des trucs qui sont pas du
tout pour nous eh ben on est forcément
malade et je les ai vécus mois 90 et à
écrire
pas de bouton parce quand ils bouffent
n'importe quoi parce qu'il moves qui
trouve évidemment n'est pas on n'est pas
habitué à ça dans quoi on peut être
malade déjà rien qu'à cause de ça et il
parle de pékin
mais non je parle pas de pékin je parle
de la jao phillip lim je voudrais dire
que là je les trouvais entière généreuse
extrêmement afin de conférer de valence
elle m'a bouleversé faudrait pas en plus
mais c'est bien de dire ça non mais
c'est pas grave elle n'est pas parce que
j'ai dit quelque chose ici mais moi je
n'aime pas en revanche les programmes de
mike horn le labellisé mike horn en
aventure trop courts ou alors de
thérapie low cost dans la jungle oui je
te dirai comment tes pieds comment tu
réagis avec les moustiques je dirai quel
humain t et j'y crois pas du tout en
fait je crois pas du tout que quand on
est privé des moyens de communication
avec malgré tout des caméras pour un
prime dans plus de rennes 6 c'est
forcément une remise en question de ses
fondamentaux
moi j'ai adoré l'âme aussi dans
l'aventuré les ponts